aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'on
retient de l'élan réformateur d'
emmanuel macron la réforme de
l'assurance chômage elle s'est arrêtée
au milieu du gué la réforme des
retraites elle n'aura pas lieu la
réforme de la dépendance non plus celle
du marché travail il n'a eu aucune
conséquence favorable donc oui il ya une
baisse statistiques du chômage
aujourd'hui il ya d'autres problèmes sur
lesquels le gouvernement ne s'attaque
pas c'est aujourd'hui le manque de main
d'oeuvre la question de la formation et
d'encourager aussi tout simplement
l'intelligence de la main mais moi je
demande une chose c'est que le
gouvernement français rendre l'argent
qu'il a capté de la hausse des prix de
l'énergie et ça suffira pas un chèque
énergie ce qu'il faut c'est deux choses
c'est baisser la fiscalité sur les
énergies et surtout c'est changer de
politique énergétique ce gouvernement
aujourd'hui il ne défend pas le
nucléaire il n'a pas ce courage là le
nucléaire c'est là qu'elle construit
plusieurs mini c'est la garantie c'est
la garantie de la stabilité des prix
j'ai pas envie qu après les gilet jaune
demain on est les gilet bleu parce qu'
une explosion du prix d'électricité ou
la facture d'eau pour les français et là
le gouvernement il a une part de
responsabilité non pas sur la demande
mondiale mais sur la manière dont ces
prix se forment et la manière dont il
peut agir donc vous vous b seriez les
taxe évidemment sur les énergies
écoutez d'abord vous dire que elle
n'était pas aussi haute ensuite vous
dire qu'on s'est battu lorsqu'il est la
hausse des prix sur les carburants vous
savez c'est la droite parlementaire qui
a bloqué la hausse des prix sur les
carburants et caf qui a dit au
gouvernement attention là vous allez
faire exploser la facture des ménages
parce qu'on parle souvent du pouvoir
d'achat pousser les gens pour pouvoir
d'achat c'est quoi c'est le prix du
logement c'est le prix de l'électricité
c'est le prix de son abonnement
téléphone c'est ça l'enjeu est tout
augmente c'est ça la réalité en mai